تايوان جزيره صغيره موجوده في المحيط
الهادي مساحتها حوالي 36 الف كيلو متر
مربع فقط لا غير عدد سكانها اقل من 24
مليون نسمه
هذه الجزيره كانت جزء من الامبراطوريه
الصينيه لقرون المضت ولكن ما حدث انه مع
نهايه الحرب العالميه الثانيه سنه 1945
اشتعلت حرب اهليه داخل الصين بين طيارين
اساسيين القوميين والشيوعيين والحرب دي
استمرت من سنه 1946 ل
1949 وانتهت بها هزيمه القوميين وانتصار
الشيوعيين لما انهزم القوميين فروا من
البر الصيني الى جزيره تايوان وهناك
اعلنوا قيام جمهوريه الصين واتخذوا من طاي
بي عاصمه لهم بس دي مش عاصمه للتيوان فقط
عاصمه لكل الصين يعني تايوان عاصمه مؤقته
طبعا لتايوان ولبر الصين اي ان جمهوريه
الصين بتمثل الصينيين في كل مكان فيما ان
الشيوعيين اعلنوا قيام جمهوريه الصين
الشعبيه واتخذوا من بكين عاصمه لهم وقالوا
الممثل الشرعي لكل الصينيين الموجودين على
البر الصيني والموجودين ايضا في تايوان
ووجد العالم نفسه امام حكومتين كل حكومه
بتقول انها الممثل الشرعي لكل الصينيين في
البر وفي البحر ولان العالم كان في بدايه
الحرب البارده فقد انقسم الى فريقين
الاتحاد السوفيتي والدول التابعه له
والواقع تحت نفوذه اعترفت ببكين ممثلا لكل
الصينيين يعني بالصين الشعبيه الشيوعيه
فيما ان الغرب بقياده الولايات المتحده
اعترف بجمهوريه الصين الموجوده في تايوان
ممثلا لكل الصينيين ولان نفوذ الغرب كان
اقوى فقد دخلت تايوان باعتبارها ممثلا لكل
الصينيين في مجلس الامن وفي الامم المتحده
واصبحت جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه لا ممثله
لها وبالتالي ظلت هذه القضيه يعني سبب
للخلافه ما بين الصين والولايات المتحده
دي قصه تايوان وطبعا من سنه 49 والى الان
قيوان طبعا في البدايه الجمهوريه القوميين
كانوا بيسعوا ان هم يستعيدوا البر البر
الصين كله وبعدين تغيرت اهدافهم الى ان هم
يظلوا منفصلين يعني يتركوا بر الصين
للشيوعيين فيما انه هم يقيموا دوله مستقله
منفصله عن الصين وكان هدف الصين الاساسي
هو استعاده تايوان على قائمه اولوياتهم من
سنه 49 والى الان